David is right.
The tester could, in fact,
test and dismiss the state using the
kind of rule David was talking about.
But, David, do you think there is
another way that this could be done?
>> So, I guess, actually,
the generator could do it as well.
So, in this case, we could also have
the generator say, I don't need to ever
generate a state that involves sending
one person over to an empty coast.
That's always going to result in a state
that the tester would have thrown out.
And it's not going to result in any
states that the tester wouldn't have
thrown out.
So, generator could do it, too.
>> That sounds like a good answer to me.
So once again, we are back to the issue
of where do we draw the balance
of responsibility between
the generator and the tester?
The important thing to note from here,
however, is that generate and test,
when endowed with the right
kind of knowledge,
can be a very powerful method.